THAT ARE YOU CAN RUN IN. WHERE
YOU WANT ONE HERE'S WHAT. IN
THE PRECEDING. THE BALLOT. YEAH.
I'M SMILING AT YOU AS WELL.
ONE
NOW COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AND
CARING AND HAS MY NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENT IN NORMAL PRACTICES
TWENTY OR THE PUBLIC CAN USED
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WELCOME
TO. A TAX THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE- AS WE COMPLY WITH THOSE
ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN DEBATE REMOTELY WITH THE USE
OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
FOR MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE
MAIL YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
ARE IT PERSONNEL WILL MUTE AND
UNMUTE THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID AND ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. WHAT'S RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE BILL NUMBER TWO WHICH
YOU ARE REFERRING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. TO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
HERE IN A MOMENT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO THREE SEVEN NINE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
NEED TO EMAIL YOU TO MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE ONE THING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING. TEN
ON THE- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE-
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AT ANY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MEET MAYBE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
AND A FEW TECHNICAL ISSUES AS
WE PROCEED TODAY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND EFFICIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ONE BILL IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BUT BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE ON THE
BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WELL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GALGIANI HERE GOES ON
HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILL
PRESENT CABALLERO. WE ARE HERE
AND NELLIE. DALY HERE YEP OF
COURSE THANK YOU LIVE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR GLAZER WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM HIS
DISTRICT OFFICE AND WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING COMMON. GEN. DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TEST A SLIM THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME OF THE ASIAN
IN ON THEM MR. AT FIRST
DISPENSED THANK WE HAVE ONE
BILL RECOMMENDED FOR CONSENT SB
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
WILK. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED AND I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND MEMBERS TO MAKE SURE
THEIR MICROPHONES ARE ON SO
YOUR VOTE MAY BE ACCURATELY
COUNTED. WITH THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CALENDAR GALGIANI I NINETY HIGH.
WILK HI WILK HI COPYRIGHT I
HAVE YOUR ONLINE AND DALY HI
NATALIE HI. OKAY WE HAVE A-
THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN NOW APPROVED SO NOW WE
WILL HEAR FROM OUR STE FIRST
AUTHORS SENATORS SCOTT WILK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHAT'S THE
RECORD IN THE BILL. OKAY YOU
CAN READ ANYTHING NO. I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ON ON HERE ABSOLUTELY SO- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO MODULATE TO
THIS MASK AND I ALSO DON'T KNOW
HOW TO KEEP MY- SIS FROM BEING
STILL LEARNING ALL. SO SB ONE
ONE ONE FIVE IS A RE
INTRODUCTION. TO MY SB TWO OH
TWO FROM LAST YEAR WHICH IS
COMMITTEE SUPPORTED. BY
CLUSTERS BILL SB ONE ONE ONE
FIVE ALLOWS FOR THE COMMERCIAL
LICENSURE OF COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS MANY PEOPLE WOULD BE
ALLOWED. TO VOLUNTEER THEIR
CANINES TO GIVE BLOOD.
CURRENTLY CANINE BLOOD DONATION
OCCURS TOO CLOSE TO CALL ANY
COMMERCIAL BLOOD BANKS FOR
CANINES MUST BE KEPT PERSONALLY
ON THE PREMISES CONTINUOUSLY
DONATING BLOOD FOR A PERIOD OF
THEIR LIVES. IT'S BEEN MUCH
CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING THE-
CAPTIVE CANINE IN A COMMUNITY
BLOOD DONATION PROGRAM WILL
ALLOW FOR DONOR CAN IT IS TO GO
HOME. WITH THEIR OWNERS.
VETERINARIANS SO FACING SAID
FORTY TO CANDLE. MANY EXISTING
BLOOD BANKS SIMPLY ARE
PROVIDING ENOUGH FOR THEIR
PRACTICES. PERSISTENT DAYDREAM
THE LIGHTS OF ANNA WHO NEED
BLOOD TRACK SHINS AN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS. IN WHICH RESULT IN
MANY PREVENTABLE DEATHS THIS.
IDEA CAME TO ME FROM THE
SOMEBODY BROUGHT AND BLACK
WHO'S VERY PROM IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND HER BELOVED
WINCED IN DIED BECAUSE ATHER
VETERINARIAN HERE. IN
SACRAMENTO DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH
BLOOD HAD TO CALL ALL OVER THE
REGION. BLOOD IN IS RIVAS ONCE
IN PASSED ON THE DRIVE FROM
SACRAMENTO TO DAVIS SO
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS FOR CRACK
CANINES WOULD OPERATE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
VETERINARIAN AND WOULD WORK
JUST THE WAY PEOPLE DONATE
BLOOD GO AND DONATE BLOOD AND
THEN GO BACK HOME. SURPRISINGLY
THIS IS A LEGAL FOR ANIMALS IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH ALL
FORTY NINE OTHER STATES ALLOW
FOR IT. AS MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS AND REINTRODUCTION OF SB
TWO OH TWO WHICH WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
BECAUSE IT DID NOT COME IN
EIGHT DAYS FOR CLOSURE OF THE
POST. THIS BILL CONTAINS THIRTY
OUT USING BLOOD SUPPLY. IS A
METRIC FOR COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS TO MEET BEFORE THE PHASE
OUT TRIGGERS FOR CLOSE COUNTY
BLOOD BANKS. BUT ALSO LIKE TO
ACCEPT AS MENTIONED EARLIER ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HIS
PROPOSED ON PAGE SIX DENOUNCED.
THE PERSON. VIEWS TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AMOUNT
OF BLOOD PRODUCED BY CLOSE
COUNTY BLOOD BANKS. AS THE
MATE. METRIC FOR COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS TO ME BEFORE THE
PHASE OUT HIS TRIGGER FOR THE
CLOSING FOR THE CLOSE CALL IN
THE BLOOD BANKS. ONCE THIS
METRIC IS MET THE SECOND IT'S A
THREE YEAR PHASE OUT FOR THE
CLOSE CALL ANY BLOOD. DO I.
TRANSITION OPERATION. JUST TO
BE CLEAR THIS CHANGE WILL NOT
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IT WILL TAKE
SOMETIME FOR COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS TO. THE SAME IN BLOCK AS
WE PRODUCED BY THE CLOSE
COLONY. WITH THE ACCEPTED A-
GIVE ME THIS BILL. THAT THE
DOUBT CLOSE. PRODUCE AN EQUAL
OF BLOOD PHASE OUT HIS
TRIGGERED WE ARE CONFIDENT THE
WILL LEAD AN OVERALL INCREASE
IN BLOOD SUPPLY HIS MORE BEEN
ARIENS OEN COMMUNITY SOURCE TO
BLOOD BANKS. THAT WITH ME TODAY
TO BUY TESTIMONY IN PERSON IS
NICHOLAS SECOND WITH THIS WITH
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
AND DOCTOR SHAUNA ONCE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AT UC DAVIS. BLOODBATH
WHO WILL TESTIFY REMOTELY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS SECOND
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS%
FOR SOSA COMPASSION LEGISLATION
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN WE THINK CENTER WILL
FOR ONCE AGAIN. IN FLORIDA
IMPORTANT ISSUE AN AUTHOR IN
THE BILL AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MADAM CHAIR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH US
UNDER DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
CREATION FOR TODAY. A BRIEF BY
SIMPLY STATING THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ARE IDENTICAL TO SB
TO A TWO. DID NOT EVEN KNOW
VOTE ON ITS WAY. WELL HERE
REGARDING THE NEW PROVISIONS
WHICH WILL FILL THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST TO PHASE OUT THE
CLOTHES CONNIE MODEL BLOOD
BANKING. WE HAVE WORKED WITH
THE GOVERNOR STAFF SEE VMA. BE
M. B. THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT A
BILL THAT ENSURES ANIMAL SAFETY
AND WELFARE. WHILE SUPPLYING
BLOOD NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIA
IS THAT COMMUNITY TO SERVE OUR
STATE. TO BE CLEAR THE PHASE
OUT OF CLOTHES CONNIE BUT
BANKING WILL NOT BE TRIGGERED
UNTIL CDFA TEAMS A SUFFICIENT
SUPPLY OF BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS ARE BEING PRODUCED
COMMITTEE BUT THANKS. THESE
MANY BLOOD BANKS WILL ADD
SORELY NEEDED BLOOD SUPPLY IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WORKS FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT'S- FOR DONOR.
TO BE AN ANIMALS WITHOUT A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT TO SHAUNA FUNDS FROM
UC DAVIS MODERATOR WILL YOU
PLEASE OPEN A LINE FOR SEAN
ELLEN'S. AFTER ON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SENATORS GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MADAM CHAIR I COMING TO ON
YOUR ON YOUR MASK AT THE PHILIP
KAPLEAU RIGHT. THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME SO FOR THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS I HAVE SERVED AS
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE UC
DAVIS VETERINARY BLOOD BACK
WHE WE STARTED OUR PROGRAM OUR
GOAL IS CREATE A MODEL
COMMUNITY BASED CANINE BLOOD
DONOR PROGRAM AND TO DEVELOP
BEST PRACTICES FOR COMMUNITY
BASED BLOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA.
SENATE STARTED OUR PROGRAM WE
HAVE COLECTED FROM OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED DOGS ON BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY AND HAVE
ADMINISTERED OVER SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED LIFESAVING CANINE BLOOD
PRODUCTS. WITH AN AVERAGE NORTH
THE SIX HUNDRED CANINE BLOOD
COLLECTION APPOINTMENTS A YEAR.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
NEVER HAD A BLOOD BORNE
INFECTION. THESE TRANSMISSION.
OR AN ADVERSE EVENT THAT WOULD
HAVE PLAYED A DONOR OR A BLOOD
RECIPIENT. IN DANGER. US OF OUR
PROGRAM IS PROOF THAT COMMUNITY
BASED BLOOD DONOR PROGRAMS CAN
PROVIDE A STATE RELIABLE AND
CONSISTENT BLOOD SUPPLY IN
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE INDEED.
TIMES IN DEMAND FOR CANINE
BLOOD GROWS DAILY AND IN TIMES
OF CRISIS SUCH AS WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING WITH COLBERT
NINETEEN THAT DEMAND IS
MAGNIFIED. BECAUSE OF THE LAW
ARE UC DAVIS THREE BLOOD BANK
CANNOT LEGALLY PROVIDE OUR
EXCESS BLOOD TO CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIANS AND AS A RESULT
WE ARE FORCED TO THROW AWAY
MANY POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING
UNITS OF BLOOD. THE TRACK. THE
HARD TRUTH THAT ANIMAL LIVES
WILL BE LOST DUE TO A LACK OF
BLOOD PRODUCTS FOR TRANSFUSIONS
UNLESS WE DO SOMETHING TO
CHANGE THE EQUATION.
UNFORTUNATELY VETERINARIANS IN
CALIFORNIA CAN ONLY LEGALLY
PURCHASE BLOOD FROM ONE OF TO
CLOSE COUNTY BLOOD. AND BLOOD
BANKS ARE UNDER NO OBLIGATION
TO FIRST PROVIDE BLOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIAN AND CAN
FREELY SELL THEIR BLOOD ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. PUT SIMPLY THIS
INEQUITY PUT IT CAN. CALIFORNIA
ELEVEN FIFTY CRUCIAL IF WE'RE
GOING TO CORRECT THIS INJUSTICE.
IN CLOSING IN ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF OUR FOUR FOOTED FAMILY
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
MY DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO SENATOR
WILK FOR BEING THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'D LIKE TO YOU
ANYWAY. A MAN AND JUST PROVIDE.
SECONDARY PARTICIPANT NUMBER
FOR TODAY'S HEARING THAT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
PARTICIPANT ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE SIX TWO
ONE. AND LET ME REPEAT THAT
PARTICIPATE AT ACCESS CODE IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE EARLIER
NUMBER THAT I GAVE TO YOU IT IS.
SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE SIX TWO
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NEXT IS DANIEL PATTON WITH
PIZZA MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR DANIEL PATTON.
ABOUT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DANIEL
PATTERN ARE YOU ON THE LINE. NO
LONGER ON THE LINE IS NO LONGER
ON THE LINE. WHEN WE GIVE HIM A
MOMENT TO SEE IF HE COMES BACK
ON THE LINE. CAN THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CHECK TO SEE IF HE IS
ENTER THE LINE AGAIN. HE IS NOT
INTO THE LINE AGAIN. OKAY. WE
WILL TRY TO COME BACK TO HIM-
AFTER WE HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AT
THIS POINT. LET'S MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
TWO BILL THREE. WE HAVE AN WHEN
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM HERE.
SEE NINE ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN.
CAME. THANK YOU AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTEEN WE WILL BEGIN.
THE GENTLEMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL FURTHER ASSIST
YOU IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
PICK UP THE HAND BEFORE. BIRTH
ONE IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIRST. TO OPEN A LINE OF
LINE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY TO SUPPORT.
YES MA'AM WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL AND A BRIEF
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY YOU HAVE
THAT POSITION. AND THANK YOU
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
FIND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN PM
WHICH FOR. WILL CONTINUE. I AM.
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
READ HI THIS IS JUDY MAN
CRUCIAL CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. EIGHT YEAH IT'S CONFUSING-
IT BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW YOUR
SURPRISE YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
PRESS ONE ZERO IN ORDER TO GET
IN THE QUEUE AND IF YOU PARK IT
AGAIN YOU TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF
THE QUEUE SO THIS IS. VERY
AWKWARD BUT HELLO EVERYBODY
NICE THAT WHILE THERE I LOVE
YOUR START I WANT TO THANK YOU
DEMAND- SO SUCH A COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION AND ORDER THE BILL
I WANT TO THANK. HER WORLD OR
STAYING WITH THEIR EFFORT AFTER
GETTING THE VETO LAST YEAR AND
ARE NOT ANSWERED THAT VETO AND.
STATE AND IT'S JUST GREAT THE
EVERYONE THERE ARE BECAUSE I'M
WATCHING AND ON THE CALLER
TELEPHONE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SECOND
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. THE
MODERATOR WILL PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE OPEN LINE OF LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE PROCEED.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DAN PAYTON AND I'M A VICE
PRESIDENT AT HE DOES PEOPLE FOR
THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS. SEEKING ON BEHALF OF
OUR MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WE THANK SENATOR WILK FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LIFESAVING
LEGISLATION WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT. AND OF COURSE WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR A
THIRD MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP. HELLO
BUT I'M MY NUMBER OF ONE NUMBER
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THE HE'S NOT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES WE WERE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT. THE
CENTER'S GOAL LAST YEAR AND
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTEEN THIS YEAR. AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTO
THE MODERATE. PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM QUEUE YOU MAY
ALSO PRESS ONE AND ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF. TO ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS. AND
HEAR FROM ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO OPPOSED THE BILL.
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE NO THERE ARE NINE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SCENE
NINE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
WE WILL BEGIN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO OPPOSE THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME YOUR IN QUEUE WHEN
YOU CHOOSE TO REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME WE ALSO
ASK IF USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE SHOWING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. YES MA'AM WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TO. THANK YOU
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON THE BILL AND A
BRIEF EXPLANATION AS TO WHY YOU
HAVE THAT POSITION. AND THANK
YOU MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE AND CALL
THE FIRST MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL CONTINUE
YEAH YES AND MY NUMBER
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE PRESS. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFFREY LEE **** OF
GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL BLOOD BANK ONE OF
THE TWO LICENSED BLOOD BANKS IN
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL BLOOD BANK IS
NOT. OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IT WE WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF LAST
YEAR'S. SB TWO OH TWO AND
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
OTHERS. ON THIS ISSUE. WHILE
THE ANIMAL BLOOD BANKS WOULD
NEVER AGREE THAT IT'S DONORS
ARE ANY LESS HAPPY OR HEALTHY-
WE WOULD AGREE TO GO. BUT
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO THE USE OUT
BASED ACTION PROVIDED THAT- THE
VETERINARIAN COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE PET OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ARE ASSURED. A
QUALITY AND SEE. AN ABUNDANT
SUPPLY OF BLOOD SO WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ITH. THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO IRON THAT OUT. WHICH I MIGHT.
THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
OPEN LINE FOR THE SECOND MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. OPEN MY
NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
YOU'RE IN MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRISTINA TO CARL REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE CDMA
HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL CDMA
SUPPORTED SENATOR WILL BE TO-
TO FROM LAST YEAR AND WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED BY. THE GOVERNOR'S.
THIS WILL TAKE AN APPROACH BY
INTENDING TO COME. TO CLOSE.
ANIMAL BLOOD BANKS IN
CALIFORNIA WELL CREATING THE
NEW DONOR MODEL. AB R. I. AND
HE WILL PET ARE FULL FORCE OF
BLOODED BLOOD PRODUCTS FOR
VETERINARIANS. WHO USE THEM FOR
LIFESAVING TRANSCRIPTIONS.
COMMUNITY DONOR MODEL INTENDED
IN THE BILL IS FUNCTIONING AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL THE BLOOD AND
BLOOD PRODUCTS PRODUCED BY
THESE DONOR MODELS MUST BE SAFE
AND THE- THE- ONLY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS. OTHER
LETTER NOTES THE CDMA LIKE TO
WORK WITH WELCOME TO MONSTERS
TO TIGHTEN UP THE BILL SO
CALLED TRIGGER. WHICH I'M-
WHICH DETERMINES WHEN THE TO
COMMERCIAL BLOOD THANKS WOULD
GO UP FIND AN AMENDMENT NUMBER
ONE IS HELPFUL THANK. YOU MADAM
CHAIR. IS RICK THE ADDITION OF
A ADVISER COMMITTEE EXPERTS AT
THE CDFA EIGHTIES VETERINARIANS
WITH ASSISTING CRAFTING
REGULATIONS PERTAINING TO.
BLOOD SAFETY ADVERSE EVENTS AND
REGION SPECIFIC DISEASES THEY
WOULD ALSO REVIEW THE DATA
RELATING TO THE TRIGGER
THRESHOLD WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR IN THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THREE NUMBER
CERTAIN. VERY MUCH MY CAN
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE WERE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. LADIES AND JOB PHONE
LINES TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
TODAY'S BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. AT THIS TIME. FOR WE HAVE
NO ONE TO ENOUGH PROPOSITION
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND NOW I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY%
MEMBERS WHO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AND ONE RIGHT SURE
THAT WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZER WHO
IS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
SEE THAT IT WAVE LESS. SENATOR
GO AHEAD THANK YOU ARE CHAIR
GALGIANI THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING TODAY. I WANT TO THANK
THE- HIS GREAT LEADERSHIP IN.
COMPASSION CARE FOR OUR FOUR
LEGGED FRIENDS DURING HIS SAYS
SERVICE IN THE SENATE AND
PREVIOUSLY IN THE ASSEMBLY I
KNOW THAT YOU FIVE MENTION THIS
BEFORE I CAN'T RECALL THE NAMES
OF YOUR PETS- BUT CENTER WHAT
WHAT WERE THEIR NAMES. AND SEE
ME BE AN EIGHT. CNN AB. YOU
KNOW WHAT I IS IN RECENT YEARS
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE SHOT A
LOT OF SENSITIVITY TO OUR
PRIVACY RIGHTS. FOLKS ADVANCED
UP PROPOSALS TO OPT IN SAID OF
OPT OUT. FOR PERMISSION TO
UTILIZE FOLKS THAT HAVE YOU AYE
IF YOU WERE TO ADD AS AS CC
MERE AB IF THEY EVER DONATED
BLOOD BEFORE CENTER WILK. BUT
NO. AND IF YOU WERE TO ASK THEM
TO OPT IN ON THIS COULD YOU CAN
AT. TALK US THROUGH IT. THERE
IS THERE IS THERE IS A WORKS
MUCH LIKE A EIGHT PEOPLE DO- IT
DOES THEY OWNERS WOULD NOT GET
PAID FOR THE BLOOD THAT WAS
DONATED AND YOU WOULD YOU TAKE
THE DOG TO THE COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANK THEY WOULD TO CREATE AND
THEN BE ABLE TO GO HOME INTO A
WALK WITH ME LATER. HOW WOULD
YOU GET THEIR PERMISSION TO OPT
IN TO THAT CENTER. WELL
OBVIOUSLY YOU YOU WOULDN'T.
WELL I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
BEST BILLS I'VE SEEN THIS YEAR
THAT WE'VE HEARD IN OUR
COMMITTEE AT AS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL LAST YEAR AND
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING. BOB PLAYED AND FIT.
AND OF SENIOR NAVY I WOULD IF I
WERE THERE TODAY I WOULD VOTE
YES ON YOUR BILL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AREA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR CAPPIELLO
PLEASE. WELL I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BACK-
DESPITE THE VETO AND I AM- I
SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ON BOTH BY THE
BLOOD BANK AND BY THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THAT I MEAN IT'S CLEAR WE-
WANTED BUT THAT SAFE AND
AVAILABLE. BUT THE FACT.
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DURING THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD
OF A PHASE OUT- FOR. FIRST TO
BE SURE THAT THERE'S BLOOD
THAT- SAFE AND AVAILABLE I'M
I'M PREPARED TO- TO SUPPORT
YOUR YOUR BILL TODAY I BELIEVE
I WAS A CO AUTHOR AND YOU LEARN
YOUR AT. I STOOD. I'D LIKE TO
BE LISTED AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING ON THIS
ON THE SUBJECT AREA THANK YOU
SO MUCH YEAH SO IT'S A AS YOUR
QUESTION HI YOU NEVER SHOULD
FALL IN LOVE WITH YOUR BILL BUT
I FELL IN LOVE WITH THIS. AND I
pWAS I WAS HEARTBROKEN. WHEN
THEY GOT BEAT OUT AND IT WAS
CAME OUT OF LEFT FIELD BECAUSE
WE WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THE ENTIRE TIME. I REALLY FELT
LIKE A BILL LAST YEAR WE- SB
TWO. BUT WITH. THE PROVISIONS
THAT THE GOVERNOR ONCE. SO HI I
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR WHAT THE
OPPONENTS SAID I AGREE WITH
THEM AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM. TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT SWEET SPOT IS TO.
WE HAVE THE PLATYPUS. THANK AND
IN THAT THE TRIGGER. THAT
BENEFITS ALL. THE THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OKAY I SEE N<c.cyan> I</c>
WOULD LIKE TO- RE REITERATE THE
AMENDMENT THAT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
TAKING YES- ONCE THE A TERM
COMMUNITY SORT AMABLE TO HAVE
MET THRESHOLD. OF YOU WILL FIVE
THREE YEAR PHASE OUT TIME FRAME
TERMINATION IS MADE CRAFT OKAY
AND THEN SECONDLY OUR
RECOMMENDATION WAS GIVEN THE
CAR CAN'T THE TWO THOUSAND.
TWENTY HERE MAY NOT ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE DEMAND FOR CAN I'M
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS SO WE
WERE RECOMMENDING THAT FROM BE
CHANGED FROM. TWENTY NINETEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY YES OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE LIKE TO
YES I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF ALL THE ON THIS BILL
IS AND TO ME I KNOW ED ISSUES
ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU. AND I DO
THAT WE ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL. IT
WAS. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
ONCE AGAIN MEMBERS PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOUR MICROPHONES ARE ON SO
THAT YOUR BILL MAYBE. EARLY
RECALL. THANK YOU THE- PAST AS
AMENDED TO. GALGIANI AYE NINETY
NINE WILK RIGHT WILK I CARRIER
COPYRIGHT BY DOLLY. TELLING
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR WELL THANK YOU MEMBERS
THIS IS THE END OF THE AGENDA
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATED PUBLIC
CAP. EIGHT IF A TEST OF PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR SIX
GINS IN WRITING TO THE
AGRICULTURE K. EIGHT OR VISIT
OUR WEB SITE COM GESTURES ARM
INTO US. AGRICULTURE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE AND WE
ARE NOW INSURANCE THANK YOU.